[Musique]
pourquoi isabelle matane se faire virer
un jour d'rtl à cause de tpm pays ah ça
y est bien arrivé ce soir c'est imbécile
à côté il a pris mon portable il
envoyait un truc et rodigan des grands
chefs
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que t'en aller alors qu'elle
était envoyée à qui alors des doux
pendant qu'elle est parti là pendant la
pub son téléphone est allumé joaillier
qui à monsieur pas qui c'est monsieur
laisse nous t'aimer chaque question
c'est le grand patron d'apple être
jamais quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
nous sommes arrivés c'est vrai mais pas
d'un vaisseau rigoler mathieu toujours
alors dit la vérité quoi il a envoyé à
ce que c'est alors foule dit le faire
mais ya christophe allanic france est
juste en dessous et à chaque question
est donc ils vont envoyer quoi mais il
envoyait un texto grossier
sur mon nom est ce que c'est vrai
j'étais en train de faire la réponse
d'un masque et on pouvait lire envoyer 3
4 comme un envoyé trois quarts de ma
visite royale
mais peut-être qu'à fait que cette
passade évident mais ça sert à quoi nous
avons gardé la même personne
non non non nous avons envoyé quoi a
battu l agence je viens josée dayan
aussi que j'ai vu des noms bavière
envoyé quoi bachelot je me sens très
loeb ce soir pour en vue d'une bonne
table
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
effectivement tu va encore avoir des
points a été mis aux normes monde à y
mourir moi oui
il s'appelle - yves attends je vais dire
le message oui c'est vrai j'ai vu
isabelle moign images de m'envoyer un
message
ouais isabelle morini bosc et on ne sait
plus ce que je te dis envie d'un plan à
trois ans mais la dernière personne à
avoir de code sur son réseau les pas de
quoi tu devrais c'est normal et on va on
va prendre deux ou trois nouvelles de
trois autres questions s'il vous plaît
qu'allez vous avez trouvé une question
par claude alexis merci et l'autre ça
après dollarama ce total la même aucune
chance à l'ennemi alors être un guide
non toujours pas moi je pense qu'ils ont
un genre bien connaître mon avenir
immédiat
tu connais tu es sur quatre simples
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas de ce monde ici franchement
c'est fou alors qu on voulait savoir
votre avenir immédiat
escudé les autres pas plus un peu
écoutant la radio quand même ici
également à très bien à l'évasion et
vous jure
elle continue des deux jeux vous dire
alors elle a un cdi à la radio elle est
là depuis 50 ans si la virile ferme la
radio et en plus c'est rtl
et je voudrais dire et sert en plus je
m'entends très bien avec votre grand
patron qui est très sympathique à moisn
lecouls mas dira si honnêtement un bon
voilà est donc maintenant bon jacques
est pas au point de faire des plans mais
elle a gardé une question offert cinq
dernières questions
un jour j'aimerais savoir oui c'est 2e
marié dont j'ai presque je me suis dit
me désirait pas qu'en 2010 mais 18 ans
déjà et un bbb encore 2018 n'implose
2018 monter les canes mariage se
prononce sur 2018 la maternité puis
celui de 2010 et début 2010 mon avis est
bientôt là matthew vous avez envoyé
alors qu'on vient de me dire alors ayez
qu'il a envoyé un message du portable
d'isabelle morini-bosc au directeur
général d'aj de zola boîte de production
s'est dit philippe stoltz
non mais quoi vous avez envie vous voyez
quoi j'en sais rien j'ai très vite aller
les revendre au regard des faits n'était
pas la même chose dit je vais regarder
après nous dire dès que vous l'avez dit
oui lol le directeur général ce qu'on
fait a répondu as nous parce que tu
m'emmerdes reste coincé parce que vous
avez mis en ménage dit c'est cette
embellie ne pas nourrir bien là on a des
retours
jamie pardon c'est un missile de mathieu
retour gpat l'abîmé je voyais bruno
masure hausse
à mesure j'ai mis me sens qu'une bonne
note ce soir je les porte à leur hôte à
la télé plutôt jaune ont masqué feriez
quoi envie de tatum ça passe je suis
désolé ça passe comme si on envoyait 15
ça passait le week-end à val de reuil
cadeau à mon chef direct à qui comme
elle s'appelle anthony anthony avril
envoyé quoi on te dit votre chef direct
à 23 heures on a envoyé trois week-ends
que je t'emmerde surtout désolé mais je
t'emmerde surtout frais à wayne quand
même saluer les brokers ça sent mal et
on va prendre ce prochain titre savait
qu ici c'est énorme ce qui se passe
parce que sauber par des colliers fogel
j'ai envie d'une vitre
[Applaudissements]
je t'aime à se poser tel sujet
mais avec ça va pousser la table est
mise à mal si on te qui travaillaient
alors d'interdire les pour noter ses
basques m'a envoyé quoi macro procédé
classique